I've been talking about the Trump what I
call insta flips or backtracking with
regard to his campaign promises we
talked about that Mexico wall more than
likely it'll be some fencing on some
part of the southern border and of
course he'll claim that he did it and
made America great again by doing it
prosecuting Hillary Clinton which he
said he would do in in one of the
debates that seems like it is no longer
a priority anymore Obama care which he
was just saying was a disaster during
the campaign he actually likes some of
those provisions quote very much and one
of the Trump major campaign promises
with tax cuts right huge tax cuts
Republicans will control the house
they'll control the Senate they'll
control the White House if there is ever
an opportunity to do major major tax
cuts it's when Republicans will control
the House Senate and White House right
well it turns out that those tax cuts
probably are not going to be as large as
Donald Trump bragged about and promised
during his campaign why well actual
people who know stuff are insisting that
they're just going to be too expensive
it would explode the deficit like we've
been saying for a year costing somewhere
between six and seven trillion dollars
this is called the real world when
Republicans are concerned your tax cuts
might be too big you've hit rock bottom
and House Republicans put together a
slightly more deficit friendly idea and
it's just it's stunning guys that the
the House Republicans have to talk sense
on tax cuts to the president-elect we're
in a bizarro world of some kind I know
this is somewhat standard but how is
this kind of going to affect the
constructive receipt tax doctrine or pay
me in 2017 type of issue it's going to
be a disaster and and when we look at
the specifics of what Trump actually
wants to do he's already revised the
income tax rates that he promised so
initially he was talking about three
income tax rates 10% 20% and 25% now he
has changed those to match those rates
proposed by the house plan to 12 percent
25 percent and 33 percent another
element of the house planet is a bigger
standard deduction on of federal taxes
there's also likely to
some negotiations over the tax rate for
small businesses and partnerships
currently the rate is at 35 percent
Trump wants to go to 15 percent for
corporations 39 percent and rather to 15
percent from nearly 40 percent for sole
proprietorships and partnerships but the
house plan would only cut that to 25
percent which is 10 points higher than
what Donald Trump wants there are major
differences Pat between what Trump has
been running on and wants to do and what
Trump is already saying he will do never
mind what the house is saying that he
should do in the things that he ran on
were spending proposals things like the
wall and the immigration task force yeah
but he never seemed to come up with a
way of paying for it because he also
promised tasks tax cuts yeah of course
that's going to raise the deficit and
this is the huge huge huge red alert
here which is that the lowest tax rate
under Trump's new plan 12% is higher
than the lowest tax rate that already
exists right now think about how
regressive this tax cut is as is usually
the case with these right-wing tax cuts
if Trump goes for the house plan there
will be a tax break for the top point
two percent through no estate tax which
is a horribly regressive tax the top tax
rate for the highest earners would go
from 39.6% the 33% the middle tax rate
would basically stay similar at 25
percent but that lowest rate would go
from 10 percent to 12 percent we're
talking about a tax increase for some of
those in the lowest tax bracket what
happened to helping the little guy
Rachel which is what Trump ran on making
America great again for the middle
classes I'm not really sure but besides
for swapping interest deduction with
expensing has he named a single tax
preference that he wants to eliminate uh
well let's see he wants to eliminate I
mean he talks about loopholes getting
rid of loopholes or something I don't
know about in waste broaden ways were
going to get rid of no I have I mean he
wants to changes to the mortgage
deduction mortgage interest deduction
that's a change right I suppose I just
haven't read anything specific yeah well
that's the problem with the Trump
proposals that there is nothing specific
and and most of them
like all of the others we've been
talking about fall apart very quickly
when it's time to actually legislate we
had a sort of not that cold day here in
Massachusetts a few days ago and so my
friend Evan and I grabbed the latest
Omaha Steaks family gift pack that they
sent me and we did some serious grilling
I now am grilling on a gas grill actual
gas and I've been pretty lazy about
charcoal I basically had electric for a
long time but the Omaha Steaks
on the gas grill are really tremendous
and for $49.99 you can get the family
gift pack at 77% off if you use the
promo code Pakman that's at Omaha Steaks
comm you type in PA que ma n into the
search bar and you get a lot of really
really great stuff including filet
mignon top sirloin boneless chicken
breasts burgers meatballs potatoes au
gratin caramel apple tartlets as well as
that infamous and famous Omaha steak
seasoning and plenty more you can go to
Omaha Steaks com enter the code Pakman
in the search bar and get the family
gift pack 77% off for david pakman show
viewers